friends I'm shooting a video tonight to
show you my key fob for my f-150 2015
f150 lariat it was giving me a warning
that the batteries were going dead so I
went and changed the batteries and it
didn't work after I put the old
batteries back into something that's odd
- something's going on with a battery
situation you can see it like I've had
this thing apart ten times
long story short though yeah all you
gotta do to get back into your truck for
one things there's a key inside this
when you open it up there's a safety key
you put it on the outside in the there's
a slot out there you put it in and then
it will allow you to get back in the
truck but then I look to the firm number
of videos and they were showing it
inside a cup holder you can see I've had
this cup holder thing out and there's a
cup holder up here in the back and the
seat the middle seat - but I saw several
videos saying that you can stick this
key fob down inside a hole inside these
cup holders well there wasn't one I've
got a f150 lariat 2015 so I pulled the
middle seat up and it's right back there
there's a hole in the very back so
here's the cup holder and way back here
if you stick the dead key fob without
the I'm not going to fit it in there but
just take my word for it as all right
there it's very dark I know but if you
put the key fob down in the hole just
like that and I hold your your you know
your your brake pedal down and push your
butt and it will start so I'm just
saying that the the videos I saw showed
you inside a cup holder I will go ahead
and correct that cup holder here to
minute I just got super frustrated
there's something what's wrong with it
but there you go that is how you can get
back in your f-150 if you go 2015 model
like me so peace driver watch subscribe
to the channel if you like